su primera parada en su gira
latinoamericana la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula ponder Legend se
reunió en Brasilia con el presidente
brasileño Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva y
anunció la entrega de unos 20 millones
de dólares para la protección de la
selva amazónica a través del fondo
amazonía creado en 2008 pero suspendido
en 2019 durante el gobierno de la
expresidente ultraderechista Jair
bolsonaro muy hablamos de la selva
amazónica la selva amazónica es una
maravilla de la naturaleza es el pulmón
verde de nuestro planeta y es un Aliado
clave contra el calentamiento global
en las conversaciones también se habló
de desbloquear el acuerdo de libre
comercio entre los cuatro países que
conforman el mercosur y la Unión Europea
que entraría en vigor a final de año si
los sudamericanos logran acordar una
postura conjunta antes de la próxima
Ronda de conversaciones
que no tiene de alguna forma nada que
pueda trabajar sobre las controversias
no es un sistema perfecto no es un
sistema migratorio tampoco perfecto
entre los cuatro países parecería muy
raro que una Unión muy perfecta como la
puede ser la Unión Europea encaje con
una Unión muy perfecta como lo que es el
mercosur no es culpa de la Unión Europea
en este caso es culpa de los cuatro
países latinoamericanos que no se han
puesto de acuerdo Pese a que la Unión
Europea es ya el mayor inversor en
América Latina el bloque europeo pone el
énfasis en la protección medioambiental
como principal compromiso para cerrar el
pacto comercial por su parte Lula
criticó las estrictas condiciones y
aseguró temer las sanciones
medioambientales
la premisa que debe existir entre socios
estratégicos es la de confianza mutua no
la desconfianza y las sanciones
esto llega en un momento crítico para la
amazonía la deforestación en Brasil
aumentó un
22,3%, respecto al año anterior el
equivalente al territorio de un país
como Israel